another day another hong kong activist
on trial this time an elderly woman
who's often taunted police by waving the
flag of britain the former colonial
power here
grandma wong is the nickname she was
given by protesters during the unrest in
2019
she also stood out because of her age 66
wong whose real name is alexandra began
demonstrating more than a decade ago
since then she's been arrested and
imprisoned multiple times we want to
to have
freedom fight for freedom please stand
in hong kong
six months ago she was arrested again
wong's already spent more than six
months in custody on wednesday the
magistrate convicted her of two charges
of a legal assembly sentencing her to 32
weeks in jail that's almost eight months
her third jail term in almost as many
years
wong made headlines three years ago
during the height of the pro-democracy
demonstrations when she vanished for 14
months she was arrested by chinese
police after crossing the border
a day earlier another elderly protester
who also once attracted attention was
sentenced to nine months for attempted
sedition
kusuyu is 75 and has stage four colon
cancer there are now concerns he may die
in prison
since 2019 more than 2
800 people have been prosecuted for
protest related offences a security law
imposed by beijing in 2020 has
effectively criminalized dissent here
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong